hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now I had
to come all the way back to the base
because for some reason when you eat too
much of the same fish your health gets
cut in half also I wanted to read the
names on the locker the first one goes
to Sarah Saba well you can tell that
stupid Reaper Leviathan that he can Bing
bong bring it on which is reference to
SCP containment breach oddly enough from
a long time ago but thank you so much
Sarah and then and this one just maybe
laughs anger wagon just set the anger
wagon is pleased which I'm assuming is
good I have no idea
did my rage compilation please the anger
wagon
so anger wagon and then Clancy Ireland
who said I was so scared when he went in
the hole which is oddly topical to what
I'm about to do now and know that I I'm
still recording from the last time so no
it's it's kind of the same recording but
it does take place in the same realistic
scenario here and what's gonna happen is
wow I did not know that my Cyclops had
that much of a light on it but what I'm
gonna do is I'm actually going to take
my Cyclops one because the USS [ __ ]
the ocean hasn't had much use lately but
also because it charges up wow I don't
have a lot of power hang on I think I
actually have a Power Cell on me because
it also charges up my seemeth and this
was kind of far away and I want to make
sure that I don't run out in the middle
of the ocean because that has happened
before where my seamoth just kind of
dies in the middle of nowhere and it's
stranded forever and I don't want to do
that so I'm not gonna do that but this
thing is slow as [ __ ] so I'm just gonna
meander my way across it I wonder if I
can breach with this thing ah holy [ __ ]
I didn't know my Cyclops was that agile
I'm gonna Ram it I'm gonna Ram might Oh
maybe it's not a good idea to ram my
lifeboat but maybe I'm just gonna try to
act like a humpback whale and just kind
of reach over it it just totally
capsized it I mean if it collapses under
the weight of a single human standing on
the top of it which it did in last
episode I wonder what an entire boats
gonna do it to it habbo poops sorry ah
[ __ ] I'm sorry I want to do it again
kinda but I got a I got a mission to
complete
don't try to bug me I also don't know
where I'm going okay I'm assuming it's
this way but I'm not hundred percent
sure like you you wouldn't think it'd be
so hard to find a giant hole in the
ground but Marga buyer doesn't know his
ass from a hole because because it works
out that was a stupid joke that was a
stupid joke effort so anyway moving on
oh I have a horn I didn't know I had a
horn did I know I have horn I don't even
remember doing the horn yay Cyclops ahoy
the USS [ __ ] the ocean is here to stay
yeah take that Sancho this is just gonna
beckon all the leviathans to my
direction it's gotta be I gotta be like
I gotta be like above it right I can
only go so deep in this thing and I
really rather not Ram anything what is
that what is that I can't even tell what
that oh I am in the mushroom forest okay
so I'm in generally in the right area I
could probably get out the seamoth
pretty soon here oh okay I think we're
good alright this should be pretty close
I need to hop out anyway so that I can
see exactly where I am so ended
esteemeth here we go
boo boo boo boo boo boo Boop here we go
dear [ __ ] duck is out in the boat
all right where we at were we close ooh
I think we were close I'm good
all right ba ba ba ba ba ba Keith you be
good I'm gonna go adventure into some
places where I shouldn't go probably cuz
I hate going in giant holes in the
ground what is that
oh that's the other wreckage okay so
that's the wreckage it was just to the
right of that and so is a Leviathan but
we're gonna ignore that we're gonna
pretend like that's not a problem until
it's already eating me whoo ah here we
go
no yes yeah this is it okay so the only
weird thing about this is I've never
seen anything like it and I just want to
get to the bottom of it it went pretty
deep whoo
oh that feels wrong oh god oh god it
feels wrong why does it keep spinning me
around like Hello
why are you still falling we're still
falling Oh God
ah ah why does it look like a bunch of
turds plastered all over the walls
why does it look like eggs eggs and/or
turds either one either one oh oh is
that it no oh was that damn it really
just looks like a bunch of lava flow so
this must be one of the inert lava
places oh hello
wait a minute whoa whoa what the hell is
you are there giant tumors growing out
of the walls here oh my god he's just
gonna explode into lava and that blast
me into oblivion
not the death means a lot in subnautica
but oh my god oh we're still going down
I thought we were going sideways holy
[ __ ] what the Frick ooh ooh ooh maybe
all this might be it ooh oh hello man
it's so big that it keeps loading in
different areas ah damn it I mean we're
still going down oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] we're
like this like the lowest I've ever seen
any feature in subnautica besides like
the end of the game drop-offs where it
actually doesn't work anymore this is
weird hello oh my god oh my God we're
lateral to it we're like we're like
inline with it this is the place
oh sorry Jesus hi I didn't even know I
could get down that far I didn't even
know it was possible I could go farther
down
what the Frick and this isn't like this
isn't like you know oh this is where the
game's supposed to be this is all real
this is all put in here this is all like
a this like a lava formation this is a
volcanic activity place like this was
intentionally designed by the developers
so this this is a play oh my god hello
hi what are you doing here what are you
having you missing you
limestone milk Oh Oh copper oh that's
nothing
okay maybe just maybe this isn't
supposed to be here but oh there's more
why why are you who would come down here
for copper and titanium but it's oh [ __ ]
this is the one this is this literally
I'm I'm really spitting a lot also I'm
like half terrified because this might
be weird like the CEO
hang on a second let's back up a little
bit why did that happen
okay why is that do that why is this do
this why did that do that did I pass
over a biome up above and whoa ah oh oh
what am I supposed to do am I supposed
to get out oh I don't want to get out oh
my god I gotta get out oh [ __ ] dude
but it's right there oh my god ah ah
what are those
what is that it's right there oh I can
go up oh okay okay so what I'm gonna do
is oh I think I can do this I just need
to go down and then I need to go back up
before everything blows up like my
seamoth and my lungs no not that I need
to actually weld it so I need to fix it
up and then when it goes down below
maximum depth it'll damage a bit but I
can get over to the other side I believe
anyway make a break here we go Yolo oh
boy this ain't gonna be good I know I
know I know but it's right there it's
right there Oh Oh God come on yeah okay
come on up up up up up up up up and here
we go okay oh my god it's right there ah
come on we're fine okay oh my god it is
literally right there it's right there I
can swim to that I could swim to that
stop spinning in a goddamn circle stop
doing that okay I can swim to that I'm
gonna keep it right here I'm gonna
repair first off just in case I need to
make a quick getaway with whatever the
hell is here might be nothing might be
something I found it I found it okay let
me just get enough oxygen because my
oxygen doesn't last very long down here
okay
that's so weird this is a pillar of lava
what's so cool okay here we go go go go
go go go go possible cave opening
possible I'm in the world's biggest cave
and you want to call it possible what
okay so this is this is it this is it oh
my god uh uh I don't like it mmm again I
want back my mommy my mommy ha ha ha
it's so weird how am I supposed to be
able to go deeper though there's stuff
down there there's something down there
I can't go down I meant maximum depth
even my Cyclops can't get this far down
that's so weird
I want to risk it I want to go down
there but I don't have enough welding
power oh my god which way is up which
way did I come from oh my god I'm
getting so lost in here what is this
place it's like the ceiling of the world
it's like what atlas would hold up on
earth uh it's just bulbous
it's just bulbous ballsacks pushing out
what is that why is there rectangular
formation underneath what is this what
is any of this am I ever gonna be able
to get out of here I don't think I will
where are we and why is this here oh
good golly is that the ground I hope so
in what way would I be able to do any of
this is this where like I am genuinely
concerned that I'm going to meet a giant
sea creature down here it is gonna be
the scariest thing I've ever seen like
how do we know these things don't exist
these things these giant underground
caverns in the ocean like huge oh its
massive where does that go
Oh possible cave opening my ass you
didn't tell me that the the the planet
that we're in is Hollow
oh I can't I can't go there can i but
it's gonna be bad
yeah kind of okay just a little bit
oh my god it's more oh it's just endless
Oh screw the dehydration I'm having to
loose what are these well these the
steps to the underworld what the hell is
this I'm sorry I've just been babbling
nonsense for the past 10 minutes because
what the hell have I gotten myself in
dude this is baloney
this is bonkers this is so weird
ah [ __ ] oh no I'm fine what do you guys
hear that you guys heard that right what
was that it's like a crevasse here oh my
god I can't go down it I can't go down
this oh there's a bottom I [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh this is so weird why is
this it what are ya what is this okay
enough of that we're gonna go what can I
say about this what can I say what is
that what does it do that what is that
why am I headed towards the heat
signature the heat signature are the
steam vents on the other on the other
side of the map does this thing like
this underground cave cavern this
underground bigger than a cave bigger
than a cavern bigger than any of that
this underground what [ __ ] what the
fudge I'm sorry okay I'm a real it in a
little bit but this is absolutely
blowing my mind right now because this
is okay let me put it in perspective why
I'm so amazed by this this cavern if I'm
right about this this goes all the way
to the other side of the map and I'm
pretty sure I'm right because I'm pretty
close to that heat signature here and
I'm slowly climbing in depth that means
that underneath everything that we've
been playing on this entire time is an
entire different world there they are
that but that's the thing that's the
grand reef that's on the other side of
the map my Cyclops which may be pinging
from over there is literally on the
other side of the frickin world right
now what the fudge what the [ __ ] how do
I get out of here can I get out of here
please tell me there's a way to get out
of here I mean if I'm looking at these
things there's got to be a way to get
out of here right there's already
creatures there's lava oh god hello what
the Frick are you what was that hello
someone's shooting a fireball oh my god
that's so cool and scary it's so school
and skits scurry it's school er II oh
that's so scary so scary my brain can't
handle the size of it oh my god so when
I was I think I was in these caves
before when I was over in this area and
I was looking for this thing if I had to
just make the right turn yeah I can get
out of here yeah if I made the right
turn I would have ended up in this cave
and going in here or maybe I went in
here and I didn't have enough depth and
I couldn't go all the way through that
is baloney
yeah the vents are right there this is
bonkers that is bonkers that means and
what that means is that when the
developers finding flesh that area out
they're going to have like literally
twice the entire size of the entire map
available there and I bet down in those
caverns they're probably not done yet
they're probably not done but there's
like formations there at the bottom
there someone went in there and they
made that just to taunt people just to
tantalize me bouche baby I thought it
was new
time what the hell okay I'm gonna stop
freaking out because it's probably
getting really old here like me just
constantly but this like this is so cool
this is what I was talking about the
last episode like I can explore this
place and I can see like just new things
everywhere I go every single place I go
I can see new things and that is just
bonkers about this game it's so cool
okay anyway I'm gonna stop freaking out
about that I can't believe I dedicated a
whole episode to just me freaking out
about this stupid cake but that cave was
not stupid it was more oh man that was
awesome Wow what what the hell is going
on here with the island I don't wasn't
there a beach over here
wasn't there a way to get on I don't
remember there being home like this oh
man
but anyway that's all the time I got for
this episode and it's getting tonight in
the next episode I promise you by the
time you come back I will be in the
process of building my new island
retreat here on the island that you guys
said I should name but I'm not gonna
coming up with names on the fly I didn't
think about this ahead of time um bubble
butt Island fumbled up big titty island
I don't know I can't come up with names
so you guys try to come up with names
all vote the best one from the comments
you guys decide what I'm gonna name my
island so thank you everybody we finally
found it you [ __ ] you stupid [ __ ]
you possible cave opening talk about the
most misleading signal in the history of
forever you had to go into it from exact
opposite sides of the entire freaking
map it was in the center of the exact
bottom portion of the goddamnit but I
found you golf
oh god dehydration do I have water I do
not I'm gonna die well [ __ ] anyway
that's the end of this episode and this
is the end for me so thank you everybody
so much for watching once again let me
know what I should name my island and
write a comment see if you give your
name on a locker I'll have new lockers
for the island so thank you again and
always I will see you in the next video
oh there I go